e aí agora que o ronaldo com você olha
que meu 23 houve não é vinho é vai
manter o convite meu pai é o primeiro
link na descrição desse vídeo que é o
primeiro link você já pode ir lá e já
pode seguir então se você precisa lá o
endereço e aí você me segue preservado
diz legais do disturbed você me segue lá
e você me segue lá um dia desses fui nos
cinemas para assistir um filme lá que
era os seis carros é um filme cada nave
é um cara muito fácil bater na tarde
desse dia das pessoas nas pessoas o k9
anda de avião explode a amansar em
câmera lenta e cara pega encantando o
cara tirou de câmera medo cara doida
aquela faixa junho e tem aquela
barraquinha para tirar no dolce vita de
perto do acerto na por do rastro do
catar no avião a câmera lenta e delicada
um tiro e foi doido aquele cara pode
clicar é [ __ ] de noel ativo em câmera
lenta não agora tem umas coisas iam de
ação que eu não consigo entender o que
houve novo filme ele sempre se esta
pessoa mas em vez de matar logo ele vai
ter que contar o plano maligno dela pra
ela porque quer a paz uma hora contou no
pano marinho dele é a chave
você achava que vai à festa na sua
personagem animal e fumado em baixo
netinho no vídeo européia eu estava lá
no fundo você
entendeu como funciona o futebol
depois vou ficar aqui ou na meia final
do jogo na argentina o meia róbson altar
mor tomar no cu ou de corpo inteiro
porque que sempre vai uma alcatéia de
pessoas para matar uma pessoa e uma
pessoa ficou lutando com carlos gomes
fica lá sem fazer pornô que em um carro
todo mundo em cima assim a tocar assim o
quê
ó bom e sempre tem aquele cara que ainda
tira tira tira tira dinheiro nunca morre
o carnaval época na vida real a falta e
leva um tiro no pé da letra tirar o sono
que morre
agora no fim cadastradas na realidade
nem 30 mil dia na barriga não morre
foi bom entrar porque assim porque entre
o filme brasileiro ficou de fora a todo
mundo prefere assistir o filme de fora
eu particularmente já assisti foi o
brasileiro quem é que não gosta do
brasileiro eu gosto agora quer saber
porque filme brasileiro câmera parece
que tem mal de parkinson vai tá tá tudo
sou eu ficar quieto você filma eu
atirando sua receita queda theresa may
tem labirintite e não pode assistir o
soldado não é da crise em gaza é
realmente nossa gestão vamos estar aqui
a comparação de um filme brasileiro para
um filme de fora de você
o a de que a idéia é a de agora não
vamos fugir
todo dinheiro do investimento
ninguém pra [ __ ] nenhum só salvar a
vida do filho da [ __ ] camelô fugiu
escada pra mim tá vendo é por isso que o
filme brasileiro que chega muito acha
que esta taxa que é e segundo é gente é
porque lá eles têm um xingamento por
geral jackie para uma parte do corpo e
tem 15 mil nome diferente isso só
reforça a teoria de que brasileiro vai
pro inferno primeiro que os outros e
essa região aquele baixo toda de trás é
é aqui é bunda rabo e hombre ocupou é
redondo está a falar com o agente fifa
espera conseguir não assistiu brasileiro
assistiu de forma que quiser eu quero
que você comente aqui embaixo qual é a
maior mentira que você já viu um filme
de ação para o filme brasileiro que você
mais gosta o filme estrangeiro que você
mais gosta
agora vou pedir para vocês que não
gostei em um filme estrangeiro deve
novato é autarquias até mall clique em
gastei agora de um brasileiro que gostei
[ __ ] gostei e não gostei parado por do
carro e fui deitar cá que eu faço esse
vídeo poderá conectar costeira no porquê
de se vingar e panóias rambor mesmo que
neste planeta no axé título ficaram
bastante barulho aqui postou de tinta
diverte corinthians modified botar o
carro que mostrei filha da [ __ ]
gostei tanto não ficar com depressão vou
ter que dar meu depoimento no caso de
família kaká não